I believe that the most important things
or the service that you provide to
others,
I think that,
uh,
it's very important to be objective and
clear thinking,
not to get lost in the two great dangers
that we have,
particularly in Irish society,
one of which is wishful thinking.
Uh,
we are always thinking that the world
and everything is going to be better
than it is.
And the other thing is hype.
Oh,
Americans tend to hype everything as a
result of that.
We do not have a sense of proper
proportion and we overdo things.
I mean,
the classic example right now is the
attack on nine slash 11.
It was a terrible thing,
but it was only a terrorist attack.
And yet the number of people in this
country who have referred to this as the
beginning of world war three and use
that as an excuse for the military
adventures that were in abroad now is I
think just astonishing.
Uh,
the hype in this country,
the sensationalism continually confuses
us and causes us to make enormous areas.
And my philosophy is avoid those things
at all costs.